momentos de recogimiento para estos
estudiantes de secundaria en uno de los
monumentos de babilla escenario de uno
de los peores crímenes perpetrados por
los nazis durante la segunda guerra
mundial el 29 de septiembre de 1941 los
judíos de kiev recibieron la orden de
reunirse a las 8 de la mañana en la
calle creyendo que iban a ser deportados
les habían dado estas instrucciones
todos deben llevar sus documentos dinero
ropa interior y otras pertenencias
cualquiera que desobedezca esta orden
será fusilado
de hecho todos ellos fueron fusilados
casi 34.000 personas en dos días
en kiev no había que estar locos
para puig aquí fue un holocausto a
balazos luego durante muchos años se
cometió otro crimen el crimen del
silencio
los soviéticos silenciaron el crimen
pero su memoria ha sobrevivido gracias a
diversas iniciativas
80 años después se está intentando
recuperar la importancia histórica de lo
que ocurrió aquí en el lugar de la mayor
masacre de los nazis quienes fusilaron a
más de un millón de judíos en ucrania
ahora visitaremos los lugares exactos
donde la gente fue fusilada en los
últimos dos años los investigadores
lograron determinar exactamente dónde
estaban estos lugares están simbolizados
por estas grandes piedras
piedras con mirillas para ver fotos de
la época no muy lejos de allí una
exposición más clásica ofrece una visión
general pero en va a villar la tendencia
es la innovación pronto se construirá
aquí un nuevo centro memorial del
holocausto
de alta tecnología e interactivo el
futuro museo será obra del cineasta ruso
ilya yanovsky lo cual no es del agrado
de todos
en el famoso documental shoah cloud land
no hay ni un grito ni una explosión pero
la obra es aún más poderosa por esto el
enfoque de yanovsky es todo lo contrario
pero no es sólo el concepto del cineasta
ruso lo que enfada a este intelectual
ucraniano a él como a muchos de sus
colegas les preocupa que este proyecto
esté financiado por oligarcas rusos
son títeres que cumplen los deseos del
kremlin
y lo que quiere es tener su caballo de
troya en ucrania
no veo ninguna otra motivación si no
trabajan bajo el control de los
investigadores ucranianos podrán pintar
la imagen de que ucrania es el país del
holocausto o creyendo creyendo lo
opuesto
el temor es que los rusos se extrapole
en el papel de los colaboradores
ucranianos no parecen realmente una
oficina pero es muy cómoda para trabajar
y le allá nos quieren todos los
apartamentos en el centro de kiev para
albergar las oficinas del memorial
algunos de los elementos de su
decoración de preguerra acabarán en el
museo hay que entender cómo era el
ambiente de aquel entonces porque todo
el mundo lo sabe ahora pero dentro de 50
años habrá desaparecido
demasiado lujoso quizás para reflejar su
época pero el cineasta es ambicioso y el
trabajo de investigación del proyecto es
titánico de passwords nuestro
presupuesto nos permite convertirlo en
una gran institución internacional
incluso desde el punto de vista
científico y educativo por ejemplo este
presupuesto nos ha permitido escanear
decenas de archivos y millones de
documentos y sergio el documento nacido
en rusia de madre judía ucraniana y lea
yanovsky defiende su posición y su
concepto a capa y espada mi mamá es una
sobreviviente del holocausto tengo
derecho a hablar de esto tiene este
proyecto derecho a ser internacional
creo que sí creo que esta historia
debería ser inmersiva e interactiva
definitivamente vivimos en una época en
la que la universidad y la
interactividad son tecnologías tan
ubicuas como el internet y los teléfonos
móviles no podemos prescindir de ellos
desde hace seis años una marcha anual
que conmemora el trayecto de los judíos
de septiembre de 1941 en la entrada del
parque ba villar resuenan ahora los
nombres de los que allí fueron
asesinados marc alexándrovich o biniak
seis años
una iniciativa del nuevo memorial al
igual que esta sinagoga con forma de
libro que domina a un lado del barranco
muy fuerte l
sobrevivimos y estamos aquí
y también me gustaría dar las gracias al
centro memorial del holocausto de villar
ya ven como todo está cambiando aquí hay
que construir el museo recibo
pero muchos de los asistentes no están
de acuerdo
los autores del proyecto gravitan en las
altas esferas del poder de un país
enemigo de ucrania es un enemigo
directivo digamos las cosas como son
varillas
esta otra instalación todo espejos y
música fue realizada por encargo del
futuro memorial el metal o fue
agujereado por balas del mismo calibre
que las de los nazis
es la manera apropiada de conmemorar la
tragedia el debate continúa
un debate que al menos tuvo el mérito de
hacer hablar de babilla